hello freak bitches but I also think
like especially with these videos that
have been coming up just women attacking
and like Anthony get saying that woman
said that he was gonna that woman who's
got like if he called the police was
going to say that he was raped she was
raped or you know attacking her or
whatever that's what he said that she
said that when she was hitting him she
was saying that she was gonna say that
he sexually assaulted her right
and by the way stay open Anthony thing
that's going on yeah the open Anthony
thing if you don't know our friends open
Anthony Anthony ku Mia was in New York
City and he was taking photographs and
he got a photograph of a woman and this
woman got very upset he took a
photograph of her so some sort of an
altercation took place some words were
exchanged she started hitting him so she
was hitting him it and if you don't know
Anthony you don't know that he's a gun
nut like a legit gun nut who actually
has a license to concealed carry in New
York City which is incredibly difficult
to obtain but here's one strike for
people who want people to have guns
Anthony never pulled out that gun never
I mean he obviously felt threatened he
was getting hit by this one woman who
Anthony's a nice guy but he is you know
51 years old
loves his drinking and I don't think he
lifts weights that much it's not like
he's like big scary you know Quinton
Jackson Rampage Jackson looking dude you
know he's a he's a thin guy he's not a
not a physically imposing guy and this
chick is beating on him and he's got a
gun on him I don't I wasn't there so
obviously I don't know what the tone the
situation was I don't know how it got
started on I've read very little about
it other than he went on this rampage
calling her an animal and a cunt and all
this difference but what's what's
hilarious is everything that he said in
his Twitter rampage that they're firing
him for he said on the radio show and
they hired him for the radio show if you
paid attention to what he said over the
years and why he's entertaining and how
he says it he gets crazy
see about racial situations he gets
crazy about certain aspects of the
african-american community and he's done
it forever and so these things that he
said after getting punched that they
were surprising too serious who had
heard him say these things and they gave
them checks it's kind of hilarious and
also like one of the things that people
are pointing out all over all over the
Twittersphere
is they're showing all these lyrics to
rap songs that serious has aired since
Anthony got fired for tweeting and the
lyrics are ridiculous I mean oh yeah
dude it's hardcore rap they air hardcore
rap lyrics so they've got you know nigga
this and shoot suck my dick and dis
bitch isn't that bitches you know the
craziest most radical you know hip-hop
shit and yet Anthony gets in trouble for
this thing that he did where he went on
this Twitter rampage and said a bunch of
shit that he's I bet you could I bet if
someone was a real Opie and Anthony fan
you could probably go back through all
the Opie and Anthony shows and piece
together him actually saying those words
that are in those tweet that series
makes money off of races that's serious
makes money off of well you know what
man here's the thing I think what
happens is that these companies get
really terrified of the Twitter storm
yeah they get like you saw that with uh
well you see a lot of time with sponsors
for Rush Limbaugh but you see it with or
I believe conservative radio in general
you see it with like Donald Trump had a
I forget what it was a tie collection or
some shit at Macy's then there were all
these people on Twitter like tweeting
the Macy's account like don't support
him because I don't remember the issue
was but they once it gets going the
company feels overwhelmed and like you
have to respond cuz a thousand people
just retweeted this thing and they I
think they just feel like the the best
route is the 48 laws of power thing you
just put a head on the chopping block
and mmmm and think later oh I see their
point of view I do if you but I don't
think they were fans of the Opie and
Anthony show that's what I think part of
what's going on I don't think they
listened I think you've learned a lot of
people complaining it's like the money
coming into good show it's a great show
it's the
reason why we're doing this show the
reason why we're doing this show is
because of Opie and Anthony a lot of
ways there's a direct chain of
influences one of them being Tom Green
Tom Green had his own show in his house
way back in the day and I remember going
over there and be like this is the
craziest shit ever
he's got server room he's got a goddamn
server room with cables all through his
living room he turned his living room
into a television show he just did a
little too early
he had a great innovative idea he did a
little too early that influenced us
Anthony Kamiya influenced me greatly
when he did live at the compound he did
he does this thing live at the compound
where he set up a studio in his house in
Long Island and in his in his basement
he has a green screen and he'll fucking
sing while he's holding guns too he's
singing songs he's singing karaoke while
he's holding assault rifles alright and
that I don't know if they have a pager
but that shit is hilarious and I saw him
doing that while he was still on Opie
and Anthony was doing it just for fun
and I was like oh my god this is genius
he set up a green screen he set up in a
real like professional stage with a
green screen behind the green screen he
would have like video of Manhattan or he
would have like like I was going to
totally steal that idea I might still
put a green screen behind me it for if
we do get that tri-quarter cry TriCaster
thing that would do it a in respect to
Anthony it's a big part of what they do
and the ethic of the Internet it seems
to be like the social ethic seems to be
evolving way quicker and way stronger
than at any time that I can ever
remember in in cultural history
I never remember these like big
movements shifts and how people talked
and behaved in the words that were
accepted in the words that weren't
accepted and you know and just with just
these giant trends that take place and
just wash through culture they didn't
they didn't move this quick before it's
because we practice like thought mass
correction which I'm not entirely
convinced is a good thing yet I still
haven't really decided if it's good or
bad but if you look at that woman who
took the flight from London to South
Africa and tweeted out that insensitive
shit about like you know like I hope I
don't get AIDS when I land in Africa or
something uh she'd finish it though she
said just kidding I'm white
yeah yeah so is even even worse so but
they work better you mean yeah that's
what made it funny before her flight
landed in South Africa I think you've
already lost her job and yep the global
uproar so that person learned that this
is not socially acceptable and then why
did they learn that because the internet
gave them that lesson well she should
have been a comedian because that would
been fucking hilarious you know if a
really funny comedian said that like
iliza shlesinger said that when she went
to africa holy shit that'd be funny is
it the wrong thing to say yes it most
certainly is yeah but if you working
women PR for some I think it was uh I
don't want to say the company but just a
big media company so you think she was
on pills or something like why would she
fucking sick I mean let it well how
could a person look within corporate
america think it's okay put some of your
Twitter I have noticed kidding I'm not
I'm white lol don't get AIDS I'm just
kidding I'm white wow yeah that's crazy
person it's funny though still funny
it's a horrible thing to say
yeah but the point is like crazy people
are being called out they're still crazy
but yeah we can call them out so you're
gonna ruin a lot of good jokes you are a
lot of jobs are people losing their jobs
like Anthony just for going on yeah well
you know the Anthony thing is it's
particularly weird because that's sort
of what he had been known for that like
you guys had a show where it was like
they were openly joking about racism all
the time like the other day he had Amy
Schumer on one of the best of shows it
was from years ago and they were talking
about interracial porn and Amy Schumer
was fucking hilarious but she was saying
that she she was so funny man it was
really funny she's so sharp um she was
saying that she's never fucked a black
guy but she likes watching black on
white porn and Anthony was talking about
how sad it was and that his his racism
won't let him watch it like his racism
won't let him watch a black guy fucking
a white girl wait there is a certain
that is pretty racist if you do if you
can't handle a black man fucking a white
person that's curating that he's joking
he's joking he is a comedian I think a
lot of people forget it it's a comedy
show that he's one of the funniest
people I know that
doesn't go on stage and yes it's a comic
he's most certainly a comedian whether
he goes on stage in front of a live
audience or he goes do you think his
rampage was meant to be funny though no
that's the problem that's part of the
problem that's not that's not done for
entertainment or then you're not then
your profession doesn't really matter
see I'm my issue with all these things
is that like many things in life they're
not black and white you know this is not
black and white I think Anthony's
awesome I love that dude
he's one of my favorite people on radio
ever he's great he's just funny as shit
he's smart it's fuck he knows a lot of
things about different things he's very
he's very interesting the way he looks
at the world he says a lot of crazy shit
about black people he does he has for a
long time I don't know his personal
experiences I don't know what he's
around where he's formulated these ideas
about certain black people but I also
know that there's a lot of black friends
Patrice and him were close you know he's
a you know black comics that come on the
show all the time that are friendly with
him he's not a mean person he's not a
bad guy if you're a nice person he'll be
nice to you too that said I don't know
what the fuck went down that night who
knows yeah you know I mean he did get
attacked which is crazy but he also at
leading up to it also used to always
talk about statistics about his city in
New York and something that about how
you know the the race issues with that
and so I think that what he because he
didn't when he went off he didn't really
say all blacks are this you know he was
kind of just talking about the person
who attacked him and was a savage you
know it was what he said yeah I called
her a continent animal and all this
different shit if it was a white chick
and he called her an animal he would
have been fine yeah and I would have
called her the same exact words it's
look it's all very tricky you know what
I always say about when whenever you see
a situation where two people get into a
fight it's not always just one guy's
fault sometimes it's both guys fault
sometimes one a different person like if
you talk to this guy it would have never
turned into a violent altercation and
maybe you would walked away shaking
hands sorry man no worries dude and
another guy talking to the same guy it
might lead to a bloody fistfight and
it's just a matter of how do you
communicate with people
who is this woman I've been I was in New
York City with this chick that I was
dating we were walking down the street
and this girl was so nice she was so
nice I mean she was next was it she
wouldn't be mean to anyone ever
no mean faces she'd have anything like
that in her so we're walking in this
black couple is walking in the same
direction and the girl steps in between
her and I and pushes this girl that I
was with just push there move bitch just
move bitch because you know we were
walking this way and they were walking
towards us and she just decided that
that was her spot so Jesus elbowed this
girl said move bitch and she pushed it
aside and I am thinking we're about go
to war I'm like we're about to go to war
and I'm gonna knock out the girl first
because I don't want to have to deal
with her while I'm hitting out of the
guy I'm like this is about to be a fight
and then did that chick just turned with
white bitches or something along the
lines like that some white and walked
away and kept going
fortunately because it was like like and
all of a sudden the crack but I was like
that was like close to a fistfight for
no reason
you know and it just happened to be that
that chick was black it just happened to
be the girl that I was with was white
and blonde but that happens there's
black assholes out there just like
there's white assholes out there there's
Chinese assholes out there you know that
doesn't make me racist that makes me
scared of people that are assholes and
they come in all forms bro I grew up in
a Boston neighborhood Jamaica there was
Jamaica Plain the place where I lived at
before I moved to Newton which is all
cushy and nice Jamaica Plain was filled
with these Irish savages they were
dangerous fucking kids these dangerous
Irish kids and if you ran into him like
they it didn't matter what race they
were it's like who's was a savage these
girls kids were savages didn't matter if
they were white or Chinese you you walk
down the wrong Street in Chinatown and
you run into some crazy Chinese gang
that wants to fuck you up you're not
happy I mean it's not it's not it's not
better that way there's all sorts of
races every race contains savages every
race contains assholes you know and the
problem is when it's a black person it's
getting attacked by a white guy you know
you got to be real specific that it's
that person that's a piece of shit and
if some other people jumped in it's them
that are pieces of shit it's not the
whole town it's not all black people
it's not you know it's just there's a
certain type of person whether it's
white or black or whatever that's a
piece of shit you know and I don't know
if it's this lady I don't know who knows
what happen to her
that that day you know who knows what
happened to her who knows what's going
on in her life and all the sudden this
guy's taking pictures at her she wants
to punch him in the face do you remember
what time it was I I was I forgot to
look to see actually what I made occur
but I think it was around 2:00 to 3:00
a.m. when the Twitter happened uh but uh
you know I understand he's if you looked
at his photos on Instagram he was taking
a lot of photos of the city a lot of
photos of cops and construction workers
and and stuff like that I get having a
great camera that you're playing like
New York's empty in your downtown and
you're taking photo know a woman's
walking in the distance yeah you're
taking her cuz it's a Odle it's a it's
cool but but but you know I don't know
what happened here but what-what does
seem to happen that he she did attack
him and yeah he didn't have a police or
a deal with the police no he doesn't
call 9-1-1 cuz you feel like they
wouldn't do anything right you know
maybe he's right
but I don't think the right way to
handle it is going on Twitter and going
fucking crazy and I mean I think that
that's something that someone does when
you just want to lash out and for him he
likes to use social media to you know to
get points across and that's a point
though the black on white violence has
been a point of interest of his for a
long time you know and there there's a
reality that it exists just like white
on black violence exist just like all
kinds of violence exist and Anthony is a
guy who's particularly concerned with
that it's one of the reasons why carries
a gun right I mean he's a rare person
that has a concealed carry permit in New
York City he's one of them it's pretty
hard he's got a big-ass fucking 90
minutes possibly so this chick is
hitting him while he's armed with a
deadly weapon and then five other people
jump in apparently and the whole thing's
chaos and I would have loved to for it
to be avoided but I think serious lost
the potential opportunity to engage in a
discussion about this about violence in
New York City about violence in general
people interacting with each other about
interacting on social media interacting
when you're hot with fucking rage and
you're just vent
dinging and ranting and console
manikanta animal and what is your actual
intent and and what is my job
as a representative of your SiriusXM am
I am allowed to be Anthony or do I have
to be Anthony that only thinks like
siriusXM wants me to think it only
tweets like Sirius XM once a tweet when
are you clocked off work exactly now and
wouldn't winner you know I'm not
supporting them right in this I'm saying
this is this is a very tricky situation
where the company has to be real careful
because part of what you do is you
promote free speech and you you have a
radio show and you have this network
that's uncensored this now this was the
coolest thing about Sirius would you get
Howard Stern on it and he could swear it
was the greatest thing of all time like
from now on he's Unchained and Opie and
Anthony are Unchained and comedy is
Unchained you can watch you can hear all
my bits
it's totally uncensored they have them
on Sirius it's beautiful so if all of a
sudden you decide that you don't like
what a guy says on Twitter so his
opinions which are very similar that
he's voiced on the radio very similar if
not identical will now be silenced it
gets a little squirrely the whole thing
is a backlash it's a backlash to the the
racism and or implied racism of his
tweets you know look did I do I wish
that he just went on the radio and
explained himself in more than 140
characters yes because I bet he could
have vented the exact same rage the next
day with no Twitter thing and people
would not have had a problem with it if
he said it with his words if he
explained what happened there's a real
problem with fucking getting out
anything super important where you don't
want to have any mistakes and how you're
being perceived with 140 characters you
know you're saying cunt animal savage
you know you know he's not talking he's
writing a bunch of shit down so you mad
that he's conveying those thoughts do
you not think that he would have those
thoughts off this chick hit him do you
expect him to be you know angelic and
his approach to violence like I don't
know what you're looking for here
because if it's just that you think that
what he said is racist have you ever
listened to that show because
and listen that show he says shit like
that all the time also if you have a job
as a show host or a pundit you really
need to be allowed to say what you want
on your social media even if it kind of
damages maybe Asian but no but but no
because look if he said all Jews need to
be thrown into an oven and pissed on
while they're on fire
no no well that right that's a little
bit different so but but is it different
because where does where does one draw
the line what if he said that he's only
joking it turns out he's actually Jewish
is that okay
I don't know nearly enough about him or
the show so I really don't know I think
it's the same thing I think when when
you say something absolutely totally
awful like that like all Jews you be
like you can't be associated with my
company right like that's not a serious
person at that point it's a crazy person
and it's a dangerous person too because
who knows what percentage of the
populations listening that's unhinged
right it's been waiting for a guy like
you to come along but he didn't do that
you know what he did is respond to a
person who attacked him and then talk in
very racial terms about the scenario and
he has in the past on the radio show
about what it's like to worry about
black violence on white people yeah and
and that's what that like The Young
Turks thing I saw I don't know if you
saw that or not but that was a problem a
racist I was one of the worst things
I've ever seen
I lost I'm sorry all respect for them
just based off of that one interview
because it was completely you can know
that they don't know the backstory they
don't know they don't listen to the show
but it's an interesting thing though
isn't it when you're looking at someone
who doesn't know Anthony doesn't know
the show doesn't know the backstory and
is responding to just deciding
everything right there you know that
he's perving that he's taking a picture
of this woman come industry not knowing
about all those other pictures that he
had taken and that he is an amateur
photographer he loves taking pictures
and a candid photo of a woman walking
down a street she's pretty and she had
long legs and said nice body look good
you know for 3:00 in the morning dressed
up let's treat yeah absolutely street
meat how dear but but they jumped on him
unfairly and that's like that was like
Fox News it was all wait aren't you
supposed to be the opposite of this no I
don't think it was like Fox News I think
it was like they perceived that
what his world I'm telling you there's a
fucking real problem with saying
something like that at 140 characters
it's stupid
like I've said some dumb shit on Twitter
before I've had people write full blogs
on like one tweet that I had there was
like a joke just a joke tweet I get that
I I get that you could decide that you
know you have a green light to write
something we did 140 characters doesn't
work it doesn't work for anything
important if you really had a situation
where you thought your life is in danger
or you thought you know you were you
know you were going to go unconscious
you're going to lose your eyesight like
apparently had like spots on his eyes
wouldn't you want to hear that like the
full version of it I think if Anthony
just would tell the full version of it
on the air and avoid the tweets notice
would have happened he would have been
able to express himself the exact same
way that fucking cunt animal he would
have been able to say whatever he wanted
he would have been able to talk in depth
about black-on-white violence which I'm
not saying that's all that exists
there's plenty of white on black
violence there's plenty I'm saying that
it exists I mean to pretend it doesn't
exist is pretty silly to me to pretend
there's not black people that will hit
white people and rob them just like to
pretend is not white people who will hit
black people and rob them of course it
exists yeah racism exists violent racism
from random people on both sides can and
does exist so is he right in saying that
it exists from then or what do you have
to qualify it first by saying that
there's a lot of piece-of-shit white
people out there as well I don't know
you know I don't know but in my opinion
what what they're doing is silly
this is a quote from Penn Jillette today
yeah Penn says this if I'm in a position
where I cross somebody who's carrying a
gun and confined themselves and hurt me
and their choice is to write angry stuff
on Twitter instead of fighting me back
wonderful Gandhi that's Gandhi yeah I
don't agree with that I think just
because you have a gun that doesn't make
you any more special and like well I
didn't use my gun it's like that
shouldn't even be on the table in the
first place well it certainly should be
on the table if someone's trying to take
your life what's the difference between
someone punishing you with their
knuckles and someone beating you to
death
have a much of a background do you have
in violence have you ever seen someone
getting knocked unconscious in a street
fight uh actually yeah but on YouTube
I've seen in real life yeah
I've seen in real life a few times and
it's terrifying I saw in real life once
in Hollywood there was a moment in front
of the comedy store we're all hanging
out it was after a show and this guy and
this other guy got in this argument and
there was traffic going by and they're
right in front of the House of Blues
which is directly across the street from
the comedy store and in the middle of
this argument there's back and forth and
it's a white guy and a black guy and you
see them start to like swing at each
other and the white guy goes into a full
panic all I remember is this guy like
standing like wincing his eyes and
flailing with his hands like literally
had just in full panic and this black
eyes I see him hit him and I see cars go
in front of it and I don't know what
happened I just I know that they're
they're hitting each other because the
white guy was flailing but I don't see
the connection and then the car goes
back you know the car passes and the
guy's flat out cold on the concrete just
in serious trouble he's in the street
there's cars going by he's in a fight
with a guy and he's completely
unconscious and everybody screaming his
cars honking this guy's out cold on the
street that guy could die easy and again
we tell you something a woman can do
that to you just like a man can do that
to you if you don't think that there's
women out there that can punch you in
the face and knock you unconscious
because you've never been punched by a
woman there's a lot of women that can
punch really fucking hard I you know
this see these snacks my friend Miriam
Miriam Nakamoto she's eight-time world
muy Thai champion she beat a man in a
kickboxing bout she's beautiful she's
nice person she makes snacks now though
that chick punches you in the face your
fucks ville you know like for real like
a regular guy
who doesn't know how to fight she'll
beat the fucking breaks off you it's not
not good so he doesn't know anything
about this girl if the girl starts
teeing off on him with left and rights
and she's got like precision punching
guess what you're going to go
unconscious yeah so should you applaud
him for not pulling out his gun yeah
yeah you shouldn't pull out a gun in
that situation and he did the right
thing
so that I agree with him yeah this one
goes far saying that he is uh Gandhi
like that's i joking yeah I know he's my
son it's written see what it's written
you get all fucked up you get all fucked
up even you the regular person yeah of
course is gonna get close it's
impossible to tell sarcasm like I I
thought that he was serious because he's
a pretty serious guy guy realizes I
realize he does a show in Vegas and shit
he's serious he's a lot of serious ideas
he is serious I mean he's joking about
that by saying he's Gandhi right yeah
but its premise is serious the premise
is absolutely serious it's true is there
any way to see a security video of how
this went down
good question good question given how I
mean serious is a big company big
implications to drop one of your biggest
hosts so well the outrage was all over
online you know I mean people went crazy
about it there's there's petitions right
now they're up to like I think last I
saw was 15,000 you know there's the
cancel once canceling it they have to be
be getting hurt by this because honestly
Howard Stern and Opie and Anthony that's
pretty much you know fueling that
channel I I would imagine that do you
know that for sure cuz I don't know what
they make their money off I have no idea
I would just be guessing well I would
imagine that Opie and Anthony is
definitely a huge pie what's a great
chai there it's a great show and by the
way if it was on the internet it would
still be awesome if they just switch to
the Internet it'd be huge I mean might
be a great opportunity for them if they
cancel Anthony if they fire Anthony does
Opie still under contract I mean how
does that work there is what Opie said
today is that him and Jim will be back
on Monday next Monday one said they
might have they might be making it the
Opie and Jim show just based on
contracts but what's interesting is is
leading up to this is how much Opie has
been talking about that he's done he's
not going to sign a contract he does he
wants to do a podcast he's done and it
this whole timing of this is very
interesting because sometimes on the
universe yeah it's very interesting very
very interesting yeah wonder man I hope
they do a podcast look the shows awesome
it's funny show to watch little Jimmy's
the funniest guy ever on radio Jim
Norton is my favorite guy ever of all
time on radio no question about it
consistently comes with the funny he's
hilarious and he's smart
he's well thought out he's an
interesting dude he's honest I really
loved Joey I think he's a hilarious
comedian too he's so fun
plus he makes me feel I don't feel like
much of a pro wrestler I hang out with
him like I thought my act had too many
dick jokes then I went to see him and I
even told him that I go dude I had the
best time and you freed me in a lot of
ways because sometimes I go man I got so
many dick jokes why I keep writing dick
jokes his whole act was dick jokes from
beginning to end and I loved it it was
awesome
I saw him at Cobbs Cobbs comedy club in
Austin Nutt cops cap city cap city
comedy club in Austin
Anthony's starting is a compound show
this week though so that's going to be
interesting to see I don't know how if
he has a lawyer if he said you know he
was gonna lawyer up nine if but what if
he can talk about and why he can't talk
about you know it's gonna be interesting
well I'm pretty sure he could probably
talk about the incident
daddy could talk about no one can keep
you from talking about a person
attacking you mm-hmm how could they keep
you from doing that any person that
could keep you from doing that it's not
a person want to be associated with they
fire you for that good imagine someone
keeping you from talking about you being
attacked like your own personal
experience how he expresses himself is
entirely up to him I think we'll
probably get a more balanced view of it
now than when it happened you know I
think he's probably going to take into
consideration all the the heat and the
bullshit and the time that's elapsed and
the motions that have relaxed and the
tension that's relaxed the sting of the
punches and he'll be able to look at it
and give you a funny assessment of it
but the the show just be better if they
go on the Internet they could do
whatever they want under times you don't
need anybody anymore I can move just
don't yeah they could move anywhere they
want you don't need anybody anymore it's
it's silly it's like the amount of
people that don't have iPods or iPhones
or can't get their phone to stream
through their radio it's common almost
everybody now it's really close you know
I mean especially if you're commuting if
you're getting on subways and shit like
that it's actually better than having
some sort of a satellite that sends it
to you and you can get it whenever you
want you could pause it you could listen
whenever you want it's just a better me
you know and the dome you're on have
three cars that have a Sirius satellite
radio I love it it's great I love the
fact that I could flip through the shit
and listen to new music I love that I
can get on the classic vinyl station and
listen to all classic rock because I'm
old as fuck I'm old as fuck and I
reminisce listen to some Bob Seger I
like it I like Sirius I'll keep it as a
product but man you got to realize what
you're selling
[Music]